44 horas después de la derrota electoral
del último domingo el presidente de
Brasil Yair bolsonaro hizo los primeros
comentarios públicos sin embargo evitó
reconocer la victoria de Lula en las
urnas En cuántos precios como presidente
de la república y ciudadano seguiré
cumpliendo todos los mandamientos de
nuestra Constitución es un honor ser el
líder de millones de brasileños
en tanto que también reivindicó el
carácter Pacífico a las protestas de
camioneros pero insinuó que no Comparte
el bloqueo total de las vías
populares los movimientos populares
actuales son el resultado de la
indignación y los sentimientos de
injusticia por la forma en que se llevó
a cabo el proceso electoral las
manifestaciones pacíficas siempre serán
bienvenidas
los transportistas han bloqueado 271
puntos en 23 de los 26 estados del país
en rechaza la victoria de Lula
entendió
nosotros estamos intentando recuperar
Brasil si ellos lo quieren a las malas
va a ser a las malas no podemos aceptar
a un ladrón en el poder
no estamos de acuerdo con las cosas que
están pasando principalmente con las
injusticias
ante el temor de desabastecimiento la
Corte Suprema ordenó a las fuerzas de
seguridad que deshagan decenas de
barricadas mientras la Policía Federal
de carreteras advirtió que está lista
para usar la fuerza para romper los
bloqueos el director de inteligencia de
la entidad no garantizó plazos para
retomar la normalidad